une invitée de marque pour le deuxième
jour de l'apparition berwick maria
gabriel commissaire européenne à
l'innovation et à la recherche
le numérique et la cyber sécurité un
enjeu majeur pour l'union européenne
avec notamment la question de la
formation
nous avons besoin d'experts aujourd'hui
il manque 300 mille experts en
cybersécurité c'est pour cela le rôle de
l'éducation le rôle des universités est
fondamentale nous avons besoin de nos
enseignants les enseignants qu'ils
puissent parler des métiers de la
cybersécurité qu'ils puissent avoir
accès à des formations des conférences
des échanges informels cette deuxième
édition permet de mettre en avant les
expériences de terrain
c'est le cas notamment du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
engagé dans la cybersécurité davantage
avec saint quentin en yvelines c'est que
lorsqu'on a une idée et qu'on veut
l'expérimenté souvent d'un très bon
accueil des équipes nous allons été
proactif à la fois avec l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pour développer des formations de niveau
master nous sommes aussi en lien avec
liste i avec l'école d'ingénieurs de lui
vs q parmi les acteurs dynamiques sur ce
territoire
roxy box et sidi comme s'il a deux
sociétés guillon courtoise à
l'initiative de la création de
l'association first la création de cette
entité a été annoncé durant la paris cei
berwick elle regroupe 7 pm spécialiste
de la cybersécurité notre ambition est
de pouvoir travailler ensemble afin de
faire émerger un écosystème de pouvoir
permettre d'adresser efficacement le
marché est donc de permettre
une amélioration globale de la niveau de
sécurité des tpe pme et surtout
accompagner les tpe et les pme dans leur
trajectoire d'innovation autour des
métiers de la cybersécurité d'après nos
informations saint-quentin-en-yvelines
serait en contact avec les collèges du
territoire et l'éducation nationale pour
orienter les stagiaires de troisième
vers les entreprises spécialistes du
numérique et en cyber sécurité